the lobby of Ramsey solutions Patrick
and Natalie are Weathers hey guys how
are ya hey Dave welcome welcome
Thanks so where do you guys live we're
from the Iowa City Iowa area very cool
and welcome to Nashville and here to do
a debt-free scream yes sir I love it how
much have you paid off a little over a
hundred $7,000
excellent and you're how long did that
take just about five years five years
and your range of income during that
time we started off a little about 85
and we're just about 120 now excellent
what do y'all do for a living
we're both physical therapist very cool
very cool so is this your house maybe
house and everything you've been oh very
cool look at that weird B ball sir years
later I tell people the average is seven
and son to pay off your home working our
stuff and people look at me like I'm
like I got one eye in the center of my
head when I tell them the average person
pays off their home and seven years well
here's one that did it in five see that
brings that 12 a person who did it in
nine it brings the average right back so
there you go so very cool for you guys
so tell us the story what happened five
years ago they got you going well we had
we had our youngest just a little bit
over five years ago and really decided
that it was time to get get motivated
and get that ghazal intense to get that
house paid off we had we had followed
your plan for years we had paid off our
student loans we paid off our cars and
we just had this left and we decided hey
we need to go for it and and get it get
it done mm-hmm
before this the mortgage just seemed too
high right and once we kind of crossed
off the other little stuff we kind of
looked at each other and said we can do
this let's do this let's go and so we
did
hey mom so is a team a team decision and
a team effort and you don't have you had
to talk the other one into it she just
cuz you'd knocked off though you already
had the experience of winning right
right okay very cool very cool so when
people hear you've paid off one hundred
and seven thousand dollars what do you
and your house holder you too
I'm 43 and I just turned 40 and you're
paid off house
yes sir what's the house worth about 250
you guys are heroes man you're awesome
I'm so proud of you when people pay I
mean you're 40 years old you pay off
your house nobody does that
when people hear that you did that and
they're looking at you like you must
have a superpowers or something and they
say you know what did you do how did you
do that how in the world and what do you
tell them the secret is well I think
communication of course and that's
something that for sure we struggled
with say I have listened to your podcast
for years and mostly while I'm jogging I
downloaded and then listened to him and
you know I always thought I heard other
people talk about how communication was
was the key factor and I thought wow we
just don't have it down every month it's
like now what there's always a fight
fight it was just we kind of dreaded it
like oh here it comes again but we stuck
with it you know we both had the same
goal in mind we were both motivated to
accomplish the same goal and that was
the key and you didn't not communicate
it just sometimes was difficult the
communication was essential you had to
go there where he wanted to or not yeah
yeah and I will give a plug for your
every dollar budget she had some crazy
spreadsheets that she used and this
really simplified things so we really
have enjoyed that the last so she's on
the jog listening to podcasts doing
spreadsheets in her head and then comes
home and puts them all out yeah that's
right
somebody might be a nerd yeah I love it
yeah go nerds I love it yeah yeah I even
have a line item for we get a quarter of
beef every year and I'm like well what
do we where do we put this okay meat I
don't understand your spreadsheet and so
the every dollar counts kind of that
took us home together communication yeah
very cool well eight thousand dollars a
month now you can spend however you want
8,000 take-home what excites you the
most about that what's some of the plans
of where you guys are headed well we've
been able to travel a little bit we took
a vacation over the summer and
we got to enjoy some time with her kids
we're good to go we went to Utah
southern Utah yeah and visited all the
national parks there and very nice
really just been able to look at you
know our future they're looking at at
making college easier for the kids and
looking at what what's the next step
been able to give and and be generous
and that's been that's been real
important to both of us as well cool is
there a certain giving thing that
happened that you recall that was a big
one that was neat all along we've tried
to prioritize tithing and giving through
our budget as number one and we've kind
of agreed that that needs to come first
and then we do the rest of the budget
but now it just allows us to kind of not
give with a little bit of a weight you
know it's kind of like okay we can give
this and it's completely free you know
we don't have to even think twice about
it you know we knew we wanted to give
but now we can do it and it's just a
freer feeling and and it's such a
blessing to be able to give whether
you're under a budget a stricter budget
or a less stricter budget you're still
under a budget and you know just to be
able to give and receive those blessings
in response is a wonderful feeling yeah
very cool
way to go YouTube's very very proud of
you thank you very cool now your kids
are how old and are they with you they
are we have Caitlyn who's 13 and Peyton
is 11 and Lukas is six all right very
cool now Iowa City's a long way to
practice a debt-free scream we practiced
in the car ads about ten hours oh my
gosh
oh my gosh so they ought to be by now
that'll be like professionals thought
they were not really loud in the car so
we'll see if it if they're gonna you
know well they've got some cookies out
there that sugar yeah Jack it up a
little get some fuel some debt-free
scream fuel going very cool well I'm
sure they're old enough and you guys
have talked this through to where they
understand that their their family trees
changed I mean they can look back and go
back on that we visited that weird guy's
office and mom and dad mama was only 40
years old and they paid off their house
and it changed our lives and they tell
their kids that your grandkids I'll hear
this story
yeah the cool I have to tell a quick
story they when the older two bought
their first iPods we tried to encourage
them to earn money
and so they they earned the money to the
cent and I'm just to look on the best
buy guys face as they took their money
and in handed over dollar at a time to
buy their iPod and you know we kind of
explained that through to them you know
and we want you to feel you gotta earn
the money and you got to hand it over to
the guy and that's what it feels like
getting rid of that much money and it
was fun experience for them I think yeah
I was a big big lesson very cool all
right we've got a copy of Chris Hogan's
retire inspired book that's the next
chapter in this hero story for you guys
you'll move on now to becoming very
wealthy and these kids will remember
this day because of that and as you do
your generosity will continue to be
outrageous and that's that's the that's
the key right there you guys so very
proud of you I'm very cool all right
it's Patrick and Natalie Caitlyn Peyton
and Lucas Iowa City one hundred and
seven thousand dollars paid off in five
years house everything 85,000 120 income
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream here we go three two one
awesomeness right there man awesome Wow
well if you don't know why that's
exciting a two hundred and fifty
thousand dollar house might have
something like a $1,900 house payment
for regular people that aren't debt free
and if you were to put that house
payment at 40 years old into an account
until you're 70 years old just the house
payment alone in a decent growth stock
mutual fund just the house payment is
about seven million dollars and I'll
talk about the rest of their stuff if
they just pay themselves a house payment
until they're 70 that's seven million
dollars which means that we're looking
at a family's probably gonna have twenty
million bucks does that blow your mind
that is power if it doesn't blow your
mind you don't have a mind oh my gosh
that's stinkin cool right there yeah I
mean that's that's talking about
changing your family tree yeah the Bible
says a good man leaves an inheritance to
his children's children and you see
those three little kids out there and
they're gonna be able to provide for
their children because of this diligence
they look out the paper and I said we
can do this and then backed it into a
plan and worked this thinking playing
there you go ma'am man that's very cool
I love it excellent job you guys this is
the Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
you